okay so everyone's heard of the top dogs
in the streaming world ninja shroud T
foo Tim the tap man people with gigantic
communities making tons of cash and
honestly fueling a lot of what we cover
on this show but what if I told you
there was a streamer who for the past
decade has quietly become one of the
biggest names in streaming and you had
no idea who he was
that's the story I want to tell you
today
[Music]
okay so our German fans probably know
that I'm talking about Montana black 88
he's one of the country's most popular
streamers it would be easy to call this
guy an overnight success since in
September of 2019 he became the most
subscribed to streamer on Twitch
according to twitch metrics surpassing
even shroud who eventually left for
mixer in October
Montana black Bastion subs oh cool but
the reality is he's been grinding out a
YouTube career since 2009 and the reason
why he got started there well the story
is pretty insane so as far as I know he
created his original YouTube channel to
tell stories about his life and upload
random gaming clips here and there now a
lot of the stories he told on his
channel involved drug abuse run-ins with
the cops Breaking and Entering
you know just general life [ __ ] these
videos which include him talking about
the time he was homeless after he got
kicked out of his grandmother's place
are what initially attracted his now 2.8
million subscribers and what's really
cool about his original channel is that
he paired these life stories about him
trying to get sober and how difficult
that was with FIFA montages and Cod
highlights and apparently that's a good
recipe for success and I guess the
gaming stuff was so successful because
in 2013 he started a second youtube
channel exclusively for gaming and now
that channel has 2.3 million subscribers
on top of the original 2.8 I mean this
dude is [ __ ] huge he also apparently
likes cars posing in front of cars and
posing in front of cars with dogs and
then he started streaming on Twitch in
2013 as well he took all the [ __ ] that
made him popular on YouTube the fits of
rage and the weirdly relatable life
stories and made it live on Twitch where
a chat can interact with him in real
time
oh yeah yeah [ __ ] this guy was so
popular that in March 2019 he published
a book about his life and apparently it
sells gangbusters for his publisher and
while his twitch community was steadily
growing and he was becoming more and
more popular in North America for some
reason that I don't fully understand his
twitch channel [ __ ] exploded in
September of 2019 so just for example in
September of 2018 he strained to an
average of 18,000 people in September of
2019 that jumped to 50,000 people and at
his peak he streamed to over a hundred
and eighty thousand viewers for people
not named ninja at the time those
numbers are insane and of course he made
sure people knew about and while twitch
doesn't officially release subscriber
numbers according to twitch metrics net
Montana black peaked out at 38,000
subscribers more than xqc more than
doctor disrespect and more than shroud
now this is important to remember
Montana black streams almost exclusively
in German on a platform where everyone
else speaks English
think about how insane that is he's not
TSM myth he's not doctor disrespect he's
not dr. Lupo he's not one of the people
you watch on a regular basis hell I had
not heard of this dude's name up until a
couple months ago and he's got millions
of followers like a lot of other
streamers Montana black is also no
stranger to controversy according to one
translated news report his apartment was
allegedly rated at the beginning of this
year due to the suspicion that he made a
[ __ ] ton of money off of illegal
gambling and according to that news
report Aris is suspected of illicit
gambling money laundering and possible
violation determined against the weapons
law now nobody really knows what the
hell is going on with this case but he
has done these kind of like casino
streams in the past and did advertise a
gambling website that is illegal in
Germany now according to a few other
translated news articles the advertising
of this illegal gambling website could
violate section 285 of the German legal
code which carries a maximum of six
months in prison holy [ __ ] dude
so apparently after his apartment got
raided Montana black hopped on stream
and boasted about the fact that he
apparently fought one of the cops I
don't know why you would do that but all
right seeing as I couldn't find any
headlines of him assaulting a police
officer and due to the fact that I
wasn't able to get an interview in time
for us publishing this video who knows
what the hell is going on and after all
of that he got hit with a seven day
twitch ban in October for maybe
allegedly saying some racist [ __ ] on
stream we don't officially know what he
said there's some reports out there that
he dropped an N bomb in somebody's
discord Channel but he took to Twitter
and in an translated tweet basically
said I said some inappropriate [ __ ] that
I shouldn't have and that's why I got
banned despite all of that he's going to
end 2019 in the top 15 streamers in
terms of subscriber count on twitch
which is pretty [ __ ] crazy when you
consider the talat days up against and
the fact that he just doesn't speak
English on a platform where everyone
else speaks English I can't stress to
you enough how crazy this story is to me
and why I wanted to talk about it you
have this German streamer who once was
addicted to drugs homeless and breaking
into cars to steal money so he could
fund his drug habits he managed to turn
his life around create two insanely
popular YouTube channels talking about
all of the [ __ ] that happened to him and
how he got sober and then he created a
twitch channel on an english-speaking
platform where he only spoke German and
he's one of the biggest names on it
it's just [ __ ] nuts to me and it's
why I wanted to share this story with
you so who thought cats was a good idea
as a stage play sure I get it but I
would love to be in the pitch meeting
for the Hollywood [ __ ] version of
cats there's a new version of the movie
going into theaters because the CGI was
so [ __ ] bad who thought this was a
good idea